hello everyone in this video we'll talk
about secretine
which is a local hormone present in the
gastrointestinal system and it's a
peptide type hormone
so secretine is a hormone that regulates
water homeostasis and that influences
alkaline environment in the duodenum so
it neutralizes the acidic
nature of chyme that is coming down from
the stomach
so cicretine chemically is a peptide
hormone
and secretine regulates several
secretion or secretory events from
stomach
pancreas and liver in this video we
would look
at this in details from a cellular point
of view
now secretine has two major function
secretin
helps to regulate the ph of duodenum in
two ways
first it inhibits the gastric secretion
and thereby preventing further
acidification of the kind
and second is stimulating the production
of
bicarbonate from the pancreas pancreas
itself
by these two methods it can regulate the
alkaline
environment in the duodenum
so secretine generally exists in the
pro-secretin format which is an inactive
format
ranging around 145 new
amino acids and it gets
cleaved to a 72 amino acid
containing peptide which is the active
format
and it is activated by gastric acid when
the ph
falls low secretin gets activated
and once secreting is activated it
indirectly leads to neutralization of
dornal ph
now recently secretary was also
discovered
to play a role in osmoregulation so
secretin other than working on the
duodenum it can also work on pituitary
gland
and in the kidneys and secretin
receptors are found in those locations
so this is the role of secreting beyond
the
gi tract secretin was one of the hormone
which was discovered
at the first by baillys and sterling
by their elegant experiment in the mouse
gastrointestinal system
so in the mouse gastrointestinal system
they knew that nervous stimulation
actually regulate these gastric
secretion so they chopped off
the gastric nerve and as a result
they expected that pancreatic secretion
would be hampered but instead
of their expectation they found the
secretion was normal and the digestion
was also normal
that means apart from these neuronal
control
there there is some control controlling
agent which is in a soluble format
and later on that soluble agent was
discovered
to be secreting so secretin
is ultimately secreted by the s cells
of duodenal mucosa
now question is how secretin regulates
pancreatic secretion so let us
understand that part
so secretin acts on the duct cells
in comparison to cholecystokinin which
works on the centrosena cells majorly
so cysteine work on that duct cell and
leads to release
of sodium bicarbonate and that
makes the
[Music]
pancreatic secretion more alkaline
so carbon dioxide is up taken from the
blood vessels which is converted to
h2co3
by the help of enzyme carbonic anhydrase
so hco3 or bicarbonate ion is obtained
from there
and sodium is transported from the blood
and it is secreted into the lumen via
active transport
and ultimately sodium bicarbonate is
formed which helps to neutralize the
hcl in the duodenum and ultimately leads
to production of sodium chloride water
and co2
so this was the role of secretin in gi
system
now it is recently found that secretine
is also secreted from the supraoptic and
paraventricular
nucleus in the hypothalamus so obviously
it has it might have a novel role to
regulate pituitary secretion or brain
physiology
so still it is not known how secretin
works in the brain
but it is it
it is expected or it is hypothesized
that hypothalamus ah it secretes from
the hypothalamus and it helps in the
release of vasopressin and thereby it
modulates the water balance in the body
overall so in this video we learn the
discovery story of secreting
we also looked at where secretine works
and at a molecular level we understood
how secreting helps to
secrete sodium bicarbonate and thereby
neutralizing the hcl coming from the
stomach so i hope that's all that kind
of
summarize the concept and if you like
this video give it a quick thumbs up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and if you like my videos
you can also uh get my entire course in
an academy use my code ap 10 to get a 10
discount and do let me know in the
comments how you like my videos thank
you